the secrets behind all the mask singer
costumes revealed et caught up with the
mastermind behind the elaborate
disguises worn on the hit Fox show
marina toy bina her resume includes
designing costumes for So You Think You
Can Dance and for pop stars like Katy
Perry and Britney Spears but joy bina
says her latest gig is the perfect
combination of her experience well you
don't really see anything this cinematic
for TV so it's great to bring it to the
viewers this unicorn is one of her 12
costumes featured on the show
she actually created 20 original
sketches in about three weeks then
narrowed it down with the help of
producers and Fox the costumes
themselves took just under two months to
make from scratch
this is poodle this is actually one of
my favorite the clues are actually
somehow put in by the designers and the
celebrities themselves they incorporate
it by what they choose and and how they
sing and what they sing this fan
favorite with actually influenced by a
Beverly Hills dog toy bina explains
quote conceptually
I wanted to create some sort of a poodle
type character that had a little bit of
an attitude that was a little more diva
as
[Music]
meanwhile toy bina tells et the rabbit
was influenced by a combination of
Donnie Darko and Edward Scissorhands
then there's the lion whose mask joy
bina says has chronicles of narnia vibes
which give it a more kid-like element it
is made with gold it's super heavy
this is like a Katy Perry to me she
reveals that this was the most different
costume and took the longest to make
quote that one was casted for over two
and a half weeks created in two personal
molds for who was wearing the mask and
then we coated it in gold
[Applause]
and here's the secret about the inside
of the monster which is the 360 cylinder
based costume quote we made sure the
base was made out of l200 foam and then
we made vents out of mesh to make sure
the air could go in and out giving them
enough oxygen to be able to sing live
and giving enough visibility of course
there's also the peacock the pineapple
and these four stunners show us who's
behind the mask the former NFL player
was unmasked and two Edina had this to
say about his costume quote if you look
at this kind of aged a soldier light
creature to me of that right there is
showing strength incredible stage
presence I would say it's all about
stage presence this is the tunnel that
the celebrities walk out while they're
dressed in full costumes and their
identities are so kept secret that their
agents and their friends all have to
arrive wearing masks themselves the
secrecy is real so much so that toy bina
says the fittings had to be done in a
private location she's only one of seven
staffers that know the true identity
behind the mask and explains quote
production everybody was kinda on the
hush-hush and have no idea who these
people are and still don't
I recognize your voice
[Music]